you're praying that there's not another
knock on the door you're praying all
night i was praying for that oh now i
was thinking please let them simmer down
because if they've if they've been like
yeah yeah yeah say less and then they
come in again
i'm just going to have to say babes
let's just
let's pack your bags let's get hotel
just come back to coffee shop
i've done all i could do
i can't face off with these yeah
[Music]
it's better you know what cause they're
called small wins yeah small wins is
better it's better than it was
yeah fam i appreciate that because
you're a pain you're a patient man like
that i would have 100 percent gone out
there a big man
are you taking a [ __ ] piss this is
every week is this every week now i
don't know
i know you would you were thinking what
are you talking about
and now we should be running my mouth
yeah all of them would have come out
yeah they were yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
you and her banging against the wall
i would have been through here you've
seen me come back in bad and bruised
and say yeah they they're gonna do what
they want
this is their office though yeah we're
gonna do what they want oh that's
hilarious
yeah we're just gonna have to block out
the noise somehow figure it out some way
somehow
um but anyway guys what it is
monday fun day fun day you know hope you
had a good sunday
that's like dave that's what you need to
watch it that's how he catches his river
okay yeah yeah so it's monday fun day
guys um we're shooting a little behind
the scenes day in the life for you guys
today so we got ellis in the studio with
us today
um
and yeah man i hope you're having a good
one
if you don't know get to know running
over to patreon pause the thing
patreon.com forward slash shooting gigs
the is an x you know what it is you know
the vibes um and then you'll get
yourself an episode every thursday
you'll get yourself some early access
you'll get yourself invited to our
monthly zoom call you'll get yourself
some discounted merch you'll get
yourself
i don't know bro
first dibs on them are the [ __ ]
exactly there's so much there's so many
benefits to it so mad benefits um so
yeah running over to there
if you are watching us on youtube make
sure you snuggle up tight to that um
subscribe button you know flick the bean
ring that bell
um and chirp sitting in the comments
standard like the video also standard um
i see a couple man shooting their shot
out there in the comments and i'd love
to see it ladies make sure you pick up
some vibes um
i see
i see someone
comment the other day something like
something along the lines of his peak
that we never see any girls like getting
chirps in the comments or chirps in the
comments and the reason is because
although all the girls are down for the
james a few i saw that
it's a fib but
was that on a
if you aim for nothing you'll hit
nothing you get me there you go you
gotta shoot there you go um
and from there
i don't think there's anything else i'll
get on that merch your boys rocking that
belong the street belong to the streets
that navy green that yeah the festive
season is among us guys so to run on
over to that um
flying off the shelf yeah merch is
continuously flying off the shelves it's
perfect it's concerning it's concerning
we're gonna have to skip up a couple
used to
but nevertheless um
well yeah we're doing our best guys so
head on over um links in the description
grab yourself some merch and uh let us
know what you think i think that's it no
more housekeeping notes no bro no more
housekeeping notes go straight to the
fun fact straight to the fun fact fire
lord flakes is gonna hit us with that
smoke let's go hit me so in japan
you're gonna hate this
i'm gonna hate this i'm not even gonna i
was about to drink a sip of water and
get comfy go just tell me all right in
japan
pranksters commonly play a game called
kancho whereby they attempt to poke an
unsuspected is this this thing the
victim in the anus when they're not
looking and shout cancho as they do it
this is the picture
nah i can kakashi sensation fam i can
already tell you now if i'm the
unsuspected victim someone's nose to get
bro blood will be shed
because you can't do that that's sexual
harassment it is that's sexual
harassment
you couldn't do that to me that's
assault them so i can't have a man run
up to you and just say cancer
not even one finger no this double team
show i'll go straight up me a shiver fam
oh crap
you already oh post up against the wall
nah that's a shake bro no no no no no no
no no no i [ __ ] say i know you would
watching you get canceled would be the
funniest thing to me
watching you get cancered would be i
will pay money to what you get cancer
i'll pay boys
i'll i'll pay the boys to run up in your
country oh my
i'd pay boys who you know you can't
scrap
do you know what i mean
i would have you a couple of members i
would have you unsuspectingly just
chilling in the cube in a shop or saturn
yeah in audi and have the whammist don
run up to you and cancho the claw at you
for you to spin around ready to swing
and look at
dwayne the rock fam nah you're livid oh
there's nothing you can do ah
fam i'd have to do science that's
disrespect whether i get banged or not i
have to do science
i don't know what i would do but in the
moment i do something for sure because
that's that's a public violation yeah is
it it's a public violation ah
but to be fair
well it's way worse but do you remember
when kegen was a thing in school
did you was that a thing in your school
i can't remember hit me well man me men
are good at kagan well man will just
yank your shorts down bruh i wasn't i
don't think it was called kegan but yes
we did i don't know what it was called
to be honest but yes people did that
might be second yeah yeah yeah if your
boxes weren't tight your tools hanging
in art class you just drop out
bro nothing worse it was cool when
you're wearing your school trousers and
that because it was a bit harder because
you had a belt maybe it was a bit harder
fan pe times no
no
no it's embarrassing man got kegged in
the basketball court yeah embarrassing
embarrassing no no i don't think it ever
happened to me
no i don't think it ever happened to me
but it definitely happened in my
secondary school it happened to me
luckily my tour didn't come out but i
remember there was one time my boy
nailed me
the worst way possible wow um
we were playing ball it was basketball
training so luckily there was no big
audience it was just the basketball team
that was there okay okay
and you know when um
there was one waste man he was two years
above me yeah and he was wham and
there's nothing i could do about it was
a [ __ ] bully and he was there and you
know the basketball cage you could do
about it you know the basketball cage
yes where the balls are yeah yeah it was
kind of end of the session okay and he
was trying to shoot and it go in the
basketball cage bro it hit the rim of
the basketball cage and smashed me in my
head my brain was shaking bro a bastard
was so heavy yeah it smashed me cleaning
my head and i was like you [ __ ] prick
i never was like
and as i'm there holding my head like
you [ __ ] dick it my boy ran behind me
cancho
yanked my shorts i said
grips my shorts down
i don't explode
i'd want to explode i didn't even pull
my shorts back up i just stood there
just like
i need
i need a savior i need satin because
because if i react yeah i'm fighting
everyone and then donny who hit me with
the head would just drop me on my ass
and then i would have cried
i would have been smashed in the head
concussed
kegged
and then dropped you had been disheveled
shaking i can't go back to that school
tomorrow
that's it and school school life's over
yeah year nine done
we made it this far year nine finished
so i just had to hold it with my [ __ ]
but in my head i was like
i'll be the coolest [ __ ] if i
can just if i can just hang and just
firm it yeah yeah yeah
sure what you want to do yeah grits my
shorts your business
i didn't have the linguistics to support
it yet because i wasn't you
so when he kept me i just thought i'm
just gonna hold this i didn't pull
nothing up for like a good 45 seconds
but in my head it was like
the bit [ __ ] is not getting kegged it's
having to bend over and pull yourself up
when your knees buckle in like that and
yeah
and you have to shimmy your shoulders
back up like yeah that's just gone
pissed yeah she's wearing a dress in the
dance club yes club the bit [ __ ] is not
getting your [ __ ] yacked out yeah yeah
it's having to pick it back up like that
shameful bro
shameful so let me just hang yeah let me
just hang let all these men lose
interest and then i'll put my [ __ ] back
up i think it works a little bit but boy
ah
it's the worst yeah definitely the worst
when you're wearing them kitchen towel
boxes i'm not going yeah every tools
just out everything's dropping
everything's dropping
that's uh no fight me
yeah
i'd rather i'd rather lose a fight than
that 100
yeah so embarrassing
it's long oh i've got new scene
i did the deed i watched um
how did they fall
i've not seen it yet but okay
so obviously i was running out about
like
i didn't like the marketing about it
just like a black western stuff
isn't like i did watch it because i was
in the mood of just like
i think it was literally like a sunday
night or a saturday night or something
it was just a chill evening had time on
my hands and it was like nothing i don't
want to watch anything interesting i
just want to watch something
and i watch it in bed and
it was a okay movie okay it wasn't good
in my opinion it wasn't bad by any means
five six out of ten i'd give it a six
okay it was it was just a cool movie
okay it was one of they said at the
beginning like i know someone commented
this a while when i was flagging it off
um
but someone mentioned that like ah
because obviously there's no such thing
as a black western
okay
um
like in historical terms but basically
they were saying in the movie they were
saying like the story is fictional but
the people the characters that we're
using are real like they really
yeah some kind of loophole i don't
understand i don't even know what that's
supposed to mean but anyway
because i remember saying like when i
was slagging off not slagging it off but
when i'm saying the reasons i didn't
want to watch it immediately someone
commented and was like ah yeah james i
know it's not a real thing but the the
characters are real
and i'm like
yeah but like
jack the ripper was real and he wasn't
the queen of england so if you show me a
like
abraham lincoln was real but he's not a
vampire slayer yeah true
true so the the movie abraham lincoln
vampire slayer if i sit there and say i
don't want to watch that [ __ ] there's no
point saying yeah but abraham lincoln
was real there's no point saying that
true i hate you um but anyway it was an
okay movie it was an okay movie and like
i said even though i do feel like the
actors were cherry-picked
to
um
because of who they are and their
notoriety in the space
um
they did do a good job because they're
good actors yeah of course so they did
an okay job the lead i think it was good
because um what i missed out
so what i was wrong about is obviously
like i said like i just feel like they
cherry-picked famous black actors who
were like very relevant
which annoys me
i didn't actually clock the actual lead
in the movie
is like an unknown actor i've never well
i've never seen him in anything before
and he did a good job okay so that made
me happy because all right cool they
gave the actual lead to an unknown is
the lead a black guy or white guy that
guy okay there's like hardly any white
people there's no like
significant white people with lines in
the movie okay um there are white people
there but like
i can't remember anyone who has like
more than one line
um so the rest of the cast are complete
are all black but yeah the lead i've
never seen him before he did a good job
idris elba obviously banged
um regina king
regina
might i don't think it's regina king
might be regina king i could be wrong i
can't remember any regina something
um boondocks lady oh it is regina king
yeah yeah she did a good job with who if
it was her in the movie or not but yeah
yeah so she did a good job she did she
had like a monologue okay i'll give it a
yeah she had one monologue in there that
was tight okay it was tight yeah yeah um
so i'll give her her flowers the lead uh
i don't know his real name but he played
a guy called nat love in there give him
his flowers um let me see obviously
idris did a good job
um
who else in there did a good job did
lake do a good job
he did do a good job he didn't really do
much
okay but he did an ik job he just did
his he did his thing the other lady from
atlanta i love jonathan mages i've seen
him before oh have you don't know i've
seen him but i've seen him before all
right cool
um
yeah the guy who the chick from atlanta
i don't know her name in real life
z is that something because with zed all
right she did okay she did okay
she did okay um so yeah the movie
overall give it six
i knew i'd seen him before he's debra
and loki
who is he and loki um
the scene is in my head it's when both
the two loki's are chatting to this
black the only probably blackberry in
loki in some like dimension thing when
they're trying to when they're trying to
find the
you know
you know the three
um like eternal
people that they pray to and blah blah
so they were trying to find who was
behind it and there was it's this black
brother
who's behind the whole thing yeah do you
not remember when they're in the room
and this is loki right
when they've discovered that they're
robots yeah and then they she went to an
elevator and then went to a room
and then the guy can disappear and
come i must have fell asleep i don't
remember this oh yeah yeah that's this
is the spreader bro show me him on they
got a picture of him in loki uh i will
no i don't remember that bit jonathan
mages loki i'll just have another makers
loki
this brother
that's him
you don't remember this episode
oh he's kang the conqueror
bro i don't remember that because you
know what's weird i i must have fell
asleep in this bit because i was
actually chatting to my boy about loki
whilst i was watching it and he kept
saying kang the conqueror can the
conqueror and i'm thinking
yeah i know he kind of conquers but i
don't remember seeing him in loki cool i
need to rewatch that bit is it not the
la is it the last episode is this is
this before they got they were facing
that weird dragon smoking yeah so i
think it's maybe two reps before all
right i'm gonna check that back out
because yeah um because canon conqueror
is i think he's coming in as like a
he's gonna be the new super villain in
like phase two of the tunnel uh not the
eternal's black face of marvel okay i
think he's gonna be one of the main
villains okay so um i need to go
re-watch that we're gonna shed a little
bit of love on the manscaped
guys it's the gift in season so guys
get yourself the gift that keeps on
giving and then gift your tool to your
missus or your man whatever it is ladies
imply make that implication
run your man that performance package
4.0 exactly running the 4.0 for
christmas christmas christmas christmas
i was going to say crimbo on christmas
or christmas yeah running that perfect
performance package 4.0 okay you got the
trimmer in there
it's gonna ex the thing
it's it's got that skin safe technology
no nicks no nicks never no nicks bro
it's all good bro smooth
it's safe it works it's light led like
nooks and crannies bro you're in there
and then christmas
is done them september babies
they're gonna unless it's not if it's a
pull-out thing it's a pull-out thing but
if we're here
september babies are on yeah yeah so
guys get yourself the gift that keeps on
giving run it over to manscape.com
um
sng is the code of course as always of
course um 20 off free shipping healthy
discount we know it's tough out here
brexit is brexit in covert is covered in
you need that discount 20 off uh with
the code sng sierra november gold you
know what it is bro
also speaking of like marvin and stuff
shangchi is now on disney i watched it i
watched it i watched it i watched it the
day came out on disney good
it was good man you know what i like to
buy it was like um
this some people are gonna think i'm
like picking size now in terms of like
the whole like oh man like what i said
about last time about crazy rich asians
like i don't want to hype around that
asian movie because this asian movie
but the representation in that movie in
shanghai was actually decent
do you know what i mean
i know what you mean it didn't feel like
promotionally i think the difference is
promotionally leading up to shanghai i
watched all the trailers i didn't feel
like they were really pushing a hardcore
this is an asian movie i didn't get that
sense for it yeah like oh yeah let's all
go watch it because it's an asian movie
i didn't i just thought it was a marvel
movie i never thought oh this is an
asian movie but they made a lot of
effort to make it very chinese
orientated
half the movie's spoken in chinese for
one
um
and like the martial arts act art aspect
the whole like um
representation in terms of
like his bedroom called katie or
whatever i can't really i think it's
regina's cool katie the dad was like
what's your channel you should use your
chinese name because of this i was
thinking let's go
yeah yeah yeah i like i like sorry to
cut you off i like the fact that he
didn't rush it because obviously it's
about him but the whole episode episode
one the whole um of shangchi was mainly
about how his pops was the original the
guy original owner of the ten rings and
now he's got this everything it was good
in terms of russia at all you did a good
job in yeah it's a good point you made
about didn't rush it because he didn't
use those rings four times i was
thinking i was literally three quarters
of the way through the movie thinking is
he gonna use the rings or have i misread
this is it just his dad
um
but yeah the movie was live it was good
it wasn't like the best marvel movie
ever um but it was like it was one of
the movies that no one can say it's a
[ __ ] movie there were bits that they
could have made better there were bits
that they could have been worse but like
no one can say it's a [ __ ] movie
um
i'm just trying to think if there's any
bits i didn't really like about it
i don't remember it i saw it like a
month ago now um i would have preferred
if his dad put up more of a scrap
against you know the deck when the dad
got killed by the the don
yes before he gave the rings to shanghi
yeah i would have preferred if he did
sign yeah yeah yeah he is his arms house
prayer yeah he's been a life
he's alive for a thousand years and he
gets gripped by one tentacle yeah and he
goes
he literally just goes to the race
he didn't do anything
he's been swinging man the whole time he
gets grips on one little thing and he
goes
it just goes i'm like what's that um was
it time to go yeah true i liked i
thought the dragon was hype
when the dragon was doing the water
things
hype i thought the dragon was hype
um
but yeah the movie was live
i didn't really like the whole
involvement of his brethren
in terms of certain things like i
thought it was cool like even her like
learning how to shoot okay and then even
her shoot in the ting for his neck i
thought all about okay cool i can buy it
that's fine she's not doing anything
extra ordinary but when um like one came
into like the restaurant and was like
you need to come and you need to come
too and you talk about both your eyes
are about to change i'm thinking she
can't do [ __ ]
she's an amateur boast
she's an amateur boy but i feel like
what's she doing i feel like that's why
i'm saying the reason why they didn't
rush it at all because i think i said to
you before i think i said on here as
well when we were discussing
i said the second i already know the
second one's gonna be better than the
first
because of the way that end bit panned
out you know
they're gonna bring them into the into
the phase two they're gonna yeah
it's clear you know yeah it's clear
doctor strange you've got spider-man
you've got the eternals hopefully
they're going to blend in there
somewhere have you heard reviews about
the eternals
i've heard some people say [ __ ] but then
i heard a guy on tick tock basically
going mad
um this is just before it came out in
the uk and i heard him going mad like i
don't know why everyone keeps saying
this [ __ ] yeah like the movie bangs it's
not is it the greatest marvel movie of
all time no but like
basically it had like
low critic reviews
but it had really low views
from like
because obviously the reviews on like
rotten tomatoes and imdb are usually by
thousands of thousands of people when
the when the main like crit critique
came out of it there was like seven
reviews oh this is before the movie
fully dropped so i had like seven
reviews and it was like a thirty on
right on tomorrow or something like that
okay so one guy on tick tock was like
i've seen it bro and it's hype it's live
okay um but then again i actually have i
don't know anyone who's seen it
i personally don't know anyone who's
seen that which is weird for me in terms
of like i don't know i don't necessarily
know what's going on with marvel at the
minute but typically with a marvel movie
everyone's seen it on the day
i don't know if we're outgrowing it i
don't know whatever that's everything
while i'm growing i just think because
because everyone's moving on to
what is it what what phase are they on
now this is phase two phase two
and it's because completely different
character well a lot of new characters a
lot of new powers a lot of because i
never used to read the comics
a lot of these faces and names are new
for me true i'm pretty sure that's the
same for so many other people that don't
read the comics yeah so
the hype isn't really there like let's
say you started watching it
from around um like iron man 3 captain
america 2 you know black panther
slowly but surely you so you could start
to connect the dots regardless of
whether you're marvel fan or not yeah
you start to connect the dots and it
goes to end game and blah blah infinity
war
these are movies yeah you have to watch
movies there's actors in these games
you know yeah it's only like two or
three movies in into the second phase so
it's not gonna be i think spider-man's
going to be the next
but everyone's going to watch spider-man
because of spider-man yeah he's bigger
he's been he's been about it so um i
don't know how thor love and thunder's
going to go i mean i'm intrigued that's
next year i think um
and there's also thingymajig as well uh
i keep forgetting that the vampire movie
keep forgetting the name of it morbius
have you seen the truth i've seen the
trait yes i have seen the trailer for it
because i remember at towards the end
when someone asked him how he was like i
am venom or something stupid like that
he's like no i'm lying i'm obvious he
says
yeah i remember so yeah morbius is
coming out i'll be intrigued to see that
i think that's going to be decent
they've got a new blade coming out i've
not seen a trailer for that but i
haven't i've seen a small teaser i think
like last year okay it might come out
i'm pretty sure it came out comic-con
earlier this year okay uh i can't
remember but anyway we'll see how it
goes hopefully like you said hopefully
it brings about more hype
i'm sure it will but i just felt like
i can only speak from personal
experience but shang chi
is the only marvel movie that i haven't
seen in cinema
and i was gutted about not seeing it in
the cinema
more for principal rather than i need to
see this movie this is going to be sick
yeah because i was happy to watch at
home
um i didn't watch black widow in the
cinema you didn't need to
i would have rather swapped them i would
have rather what i watched back with in
the cinema i would rather watch black
widow at home and shangshi in the um in
the cinema shanghai was hype i i
honestly did not think black widow was
that good yeah remember you're saying so
i thought that was the worst marvel
movie out actually no it's not
for one thor one in captain america
captain america
captain america one is the worst film
one of the worst ones i've ever seen
but i only give it as flowers because of
the growth from one to three yeah
because of the plot of character
numerical one
but the reason why because i've seen it
maybe like two or three times now and
there was a time where i was watching
marvel movies back to back to back to
like see look at easter eggs and stuff
when i watched one again and i think i
watched i don't think i watched two
necks i watched whichever one was in the
chronological order
i enjoyed watching one again if that
makes sense because i was looking for
the teaser yeah
i was like i've seen it before i don't
even need to concentrate i'm just
watching it to find new things and i
enjoyed it that way fair play you've got
free time no this was this was not
recently oh it was timing i was gonna
say this was during lockdown okay
um
but yeah i um
[Music]
i hated captain america one i think the
only first one because even all right to
be fair i moved iron man one was lit
that was a game changer that was a game
changer we had never seen movies like
that before it was hype you ain't seen
movies
iron man one was i think my favorite
first i think the best job they did out
of any of the first ones was guardians
of the galaxy that was a good movie
galaxy one considering a lot of people
don't even know anything about guardians
of the galaxy you wouldn't even know it
was a marvel movie it could have been a
standalone movie bro guardians of the
galaxy is a sick man it was a sick movie
yeah
it is a really sick movie um but anyway
that's enough movie chat for today um
are they interested in fan requests
every day okay
um not even a fan request this is
actually a comment that made me it
sweetened me in terms of like
obviously the motto is chirps in the
comments jobs are taking the comments
one guy posted he even messaged or
something and just said
i'm intentionally not chirpsing in the
comments because just sometimes madame
just want to get chirps too
sometimes i want to get chirps back i
think i saw that as well i was thinking
bro it's true it is true chirps me it is
true sometimes chirps means me don't
just
fam i've received a dm
i think i can't remember when it was
she messaged me saying this is one of my
because i'll show you my face i sent you
a screenshot of my finger before and he
said you said bear requests it was one
of these [ __ ] requests
just pause you there yeah we'll come
back to this let's put a pin on that the
most disrespectful thing i've ever seen
from when you screenshotted that thing
and i saw 26 requests i was like how
dare you
these men love you bruv and you've got
26 requests sitting in there sometimes i
just come back i'm so busy bro when i'm
at work i can't be bothered
anyway
um
i was scrolling through and then she
dm'd me saying
no hi no nothing literally my friend
wants to know if you're single
and that was it that's like i would
delete that
i would have deleted it's like
one you're a liar
it's not for your friend you're
obviously trying to
bait me yeah to type
so you've now got you can show your
friends that we're talking or some
[ __ ] ain't got time for [ __ ]
like that bro have you got time for [ __ ]
like that chirps me if you want to
cherish me trap should be your chest
then maybe
yeah yeah yeah maybe i'll talk to you
yeah but i probably won't yeah probably
not but i will at least respect you
exactly at least don't don't
bring up some kerfuffle about my friend
wants to know if you're single yeah yeah
let your friend hold me then yeah yeah
what were you doing here exactly it's
not even in person this is not primary
school
it's not yeah it's not chess case bro
it's not what
what did i say
kiss chase
as soon as i said it i heard what i said
that's hilarious that's hilarious um
yeah chirps yeah ladies need to get out
there sometimes and chirps man bro
that's it just send him something and
chirps him it will make a guy's day it
would it would depending on who it's
wrong but yeah it's wrong but like man
out there will there's certain man out
there that just
eat
like eat sleep and drink chirps in
and they're tired of it they get nothing
back like the the something that makes
their date yeah i know
dangling characters dangling carrots
certain man will go like for like with a
ting slide in this dm's
ed why are you dangling this carrot
floor that's why i don't understand so
to do someone a favor and just chirps
him like
follow him
go if you if you want to get the
assurance go a little like for like in
the pics
and don't wait for him to slide in
it will make his weak react to his
[ __ ] latest thing and then just
charge chirps
him yeah gasps
he would be gas
most guys out there would be very
gastric because they never get chirps
they never get chirps they just had to
be out there shooting their shot all the
time and sometimes it lands they're
excited just to get up like just their
lander chirps
in their wildest dreams they will never
get moving exactly exactly yeah so
ladies done do yourself a favor like
just just
just chirp someone one time even if
you're not even gonna go forward with it
long term
just traps them a little bit because you
i know yes love to flirt when they're
bored anyway of course one day when
you're bored but
one day when you're bored shoot your
shot to one guy
never know where it might take you um
just be out right with it and just about
i'm here to chirps
he will crumble the pretty look at his
phone is shake he'll look at his
screenshot
all these boys
made his week
i'm here to church with the little the
height
here to chirps
he'll be just that's hilarious he'll be
gassed that is hilarious yeah yeah yeah
but yeah i just wanted to plug that in
there man sometimes guys guys need a
chops too you do they need a cuddle and
a church we do
just to get through the day
just to get through the day because it's
hard out here man oh that's hilarious um
but yeah with all these icks and stuff
like that sometimes we need a we need a
chirps
because we know how much we're hated
it's it's
it's actually embarrassing how much
we're headed
like
it's actually embarrassing
like remember i remember jay said in our
group chat like women literally just put
up with us oh yeah they're happy to be
they're not happy to be here we're a
nine to five to them
they're just we're a requirement oh it's
it's not a luxury yes it's not a
requirement
and they resent it so much
yeah i'm i'm like it's a declaration
about i'm certain
women can't stand being attracted to men
they can't i'm certain of it they hate
it facts i'm certain i've eaten it they
can't stand it and i'm pretty sure i
said that last time and no one's done no
one's said anything different they've
not denied it yeah no one said no i love
being attracted to guys no one will ever
say that they won't
even if they believe it they don't want
to be the one yeah they don't want to be
that one yeah yeah they've got to keep
their mouth quiet yeah man um and
speaking of since we're just in the
comments bit i never really i never
really reacted
i don't know what is my words today bro
i can't
speak a fluid sentence
right
i never really get triggered
by
comments yeah but fam
i've never ever
seen people turn on their own kind like
i have when we said you're a [ __ ] if
you ask a girl her body count
i
this is the tick tock one
i was scrolling through the comments it
was last week just gone by i can't
remember what day and i think the first
either the top comment or the second
comment had a lot of replies
but i wasn't reading that i read like i
skimmed through her a bit
and then i started reading the back and
forth for a bit for with
them the main person i was thinking
this is long like this is just long bro
yeah this is just long yeah i was like
so i can't remember the main just about
the time i read i was like i'm not even
gonna entertain this fam i'm not even
never seen man turn on their own kind
like that disgraceful behavior couple
man were in that corner yeah like yeah
you don't ask you don't ask [ __ ] that
you don't want you don't want an answer
to it it's solid this is basic maths of
course um but yeah certain man in there
were vexed they were upset
yeah yeah talking about like
basically like the long story short no
one can never to tell me that asking the
guy how many guys she's slept with is
not only a quick insecure question
no one can ever tell me that i don't
care who you are you can you can beef in
the comments all you want you can go
back and forth
however many guests want to beef you in
there it doesn't matter to me you can
never tell me you're not insecure if
you're asking someone how many people
are set with but bear if it was just
like nah nah nah nah nah what it makes
you [ __ ] because you want to find out
like basically like
um the general gist of it is she's worth
being your wife like you can't watch
someone who said well
why
why why
why like it's just such a you question
it is like if
it's okay for her to love sex too but
the big thing is as well is if you put
it this way right because most people
will say like double digits is a no
right let's just say let's just say just
put this this way let's just say
someone is sexually active once they
turn 18. let's just say you take this
girl right
she starts sleeping on guys when she's
18.
she doesn't she dates guys she doesn't
sleep with them for three months
and then she sleeps with them for
another two months
and then whatever happens goes wrong
doesn't talk to anyone for another month
just works on herself for a month and
then starts another talking stage for
another three months then sleeps with
them
two months
that's two guys a year by the time she's
25 she slept with 14 guys
you look at that on a broad spectrum and
you blow ashes like she's up for 14 guys
big man she sleeps with one guy every
six months if you break it down she
breaks down fine in the moment but if
that's the thing as well if you never
asked her that
if you asked her and she said i said in
14 guys you're like oh yuck yeah but if
you've never asked her i started dating
her you'd be thinking big man this
girl's long brother yeah
for three months i'm trying to not
i ain't even seen the lips
the labels i seen it
i ain't sniff nothing
this goes this girl she must have never
had sex before yeah like this is long
but yeah yeah yeah yeah but these times
if you ask her number you'll think she's
a slack
very true so shut up literally literally
anyone who had any discrepancy with that
statement that we made shut up
you're an idiot brother a little [ __ ]
you're a [ __ ] you're a little boy
that's it yeah yeah and one guy was like
oh these guys don't truly believe that
they care they care again
i read it i was loosening up my
shoulders
i tell you i've never been triggered
like that before i was thinking these
men are turning on their own kind yeah
mad no bro matt
i need to find it just give me a second
i need to find it
oh my days i found on the on the way to
the stu today
um so do you know this [ __ ] called um
oloni
on twitter
yeah she um
she was the one that did the original
like sorry i fell asleep
threatened i think she did totally she
did the original story i felt like you
said so i think you said so so someone
had
quote tweeted something that she tweeted
so it was something along the lines of
ladies every time she tweeted something
like ladies let's have some fun you
already know people are sending their
dms yeah people are sending her dms so i
just need to find where it was just give
me a second
[ __ ] hell i was reading on the trains
and i was like oh my god
it's chaos
everything is just women on women in
chaos women on women chaos oh
i just need to find the original because
there was one specific one i read i was
like you're a mug
you're actually a mug i'm excited you
wait all right this is the one yeah this
is the one
so
i'll read the context
ladies let's have some fun and she's
like ladies and ladies only i want you
to dm me the craziest shadiest thing you
have ever done to a woman
who you felt was moving to your partner
oh okay
and then the one i read first was this
she's a mug
[Music]
is that the one was that the one
this is the one
and there was another one already okay
cool
she's like hi this is a finster so
please keep my name private i used to
live in a shared house with this one cow
during the second year of uni yeah yeah
this one cow
um
we would never really speak slash see
each other but when my boyfriend would
come around she'd go to the kitchen in
her worn out bra and panties
she'd try and flirt with him and offered
to cook him a meal i ignored it until
one day she came her
until one day she came home drunk banged
on my door and screamed for his name wow
that was the last straw
a few weeks later her coursework was due
i used i used wireless mac addressing
filtering and blocked the internet on
her laptop and her phone for three hours
she missed her deadline and she had to
resubmit a 40 cap
to add to that she was in the third year
i was in my second she finished with 56
overall at 2.2 to think she would have
gotten a 2.1 if she wasn't a [ __ ]
can you imagine
can you imagine just because well to be
fair i understand the fact that she was
trying to move to a man but it's like
just call her a dick just call her out
don't ruin her degree call her out you
know
just be like yo
this is an on yeah this is just not on
stop trying to move to my
but don't move to my man there was
another one i read bro
she got her 2-2 instead of a 2-1
because she flirted with her man
i don't know what that's about i don't
know what that's about
i don't know what that's about i can
never imagine my woman
let's say we lived in the same yard
never imagined we're coming home drunk
banging on you james
i i won't be able to face you but my
eyes what's going on
i won't be able to face dead at night
i'm just snoring she's shouting james
nah james
i would say leave her out bro i remember
there was one time speaking of slightly
similar that's one time
my ex in uni first year of uni in
leicester yeah yeah yeah she lived with
like two girls yeah no yeah two guys two
girls and two guys okay in her like
apartment yeah yeah
one of the guy was just some weeb who
just sat in his room and just played on
his pc all day all night you never heard
from my mom yeah yeah one guy with some
black don and he used to always have
whenever i was there he would have all
his boys there making up bear noise in
the kitchen bro
fam
one time we me and her chilling in bed
trying to watch a movie all i can hear
in the kitchen
the other yacht that she lives with is
all in there
they're all sweet
um
and there's just like four blackberries
there's one white girl she lived with
and obviously me and her
in her room i mean noise noise noise
obviously you know what i'm just kissing
my teeth finger it's fine it's their
apartment
yeah
they know i'm in there
all i'm hearing is
danielle daniel come on
yo come on come on dude i'm like
fam
i thought eric she went out there said
oh i'm with my boyfriend like can you
guys stop did it like yeah yeah yeah say
like
was it kitty yeah back in the day say it
easy easy
yeah yeah what mama's in here saying
easy saying easy fam close the door
okay
and my wife beat her and sleep for time
shorts with three days of training
[Laughter]
i left out fam my chest was indented
leapt out laps fled yeah fam ting is as
well what's mad what's actually mad yeah
is is the weirdest situation because
there's four men in there
my age yeah there's four men in there my
age and i'm thinking
um
i'm not a man if i stay in here and
don't say anything yeah i'm physically
not i could never come to you man
tomorrow for that you never guess what
happened last night
these moms were banging calling for my
girl they opened her bedroom door when
we were in there bear shout and
everything she told them to stop and
they just didn't stop they just kept
doing it all night fam i'm not a man if
i came back to carve to tell you man
that happened and you knew man said what
did you do and i was like what could i
do i just sat there and took it
i'm not a man but for
that's probably the most scared i've
ever been but most vexed because
obviously i'm at boiling point now
there's no way i can simmer down yeah
i have to do something about it because
she's already come out and said don't do
it these times these men are coming in
the room that's that's a vile found that
fire
bro that's a vial coming in the room
so i'm like
cool so as i'm walking to the door
to beef them i'm thinking
in the next 10 seconds i could be
unconscious
i don't know how does this form there's
nothing there's no way i'm gonna win bro
i'm gonna come out there with my chest
up but there's no way i'm gonna win yeah
i've got no size on me bro
i've been training for two weeks oh my
god i have no size on me i've got no one
back in it there's me
and four men so i rolled out there
obviously on a hyped thing
slammed the door i was just like
obviously the same [ __ ] bro
the whole time my knees are shaking
because i'm thinking i'm just going to
talk and i have to stop talking and when
i stop talking i don't know what's going
to happen yeah yeah yeah they're either
going to be like all right
we're just [ __ ] around here my bad my
bad for me all right say let's see bless
drapes me by my neck
beat the [ __ ] out of me and send me back
in the yard that drinks my girl out next
the door like let's stop
your head back
do you see
hilarious luckily it was the former
luckily the man was like
and i went back in there
there's a bit actually that's a funny
there's a funny point in how do they
form okay obviously when they're having
a standoff thing not to spoil anything
when it happens there's a there's a bear
in there as the main guy when they're
having a standoff
pistol's drawn
donning will tell he can tell if who's a
bat and who's not mm-hmm because he'll
say tell them take a deep breath in and
then they take a deep breath in and
they'll say and then he'll say exhale
and then if they're not about it you'll
hear their voice shake
yeah i never stop
if he hears that shake he tells them
what you call down from that's not let's
not do this you're not about it yeah and
they know they heard their voice family
they heard their breath they don't know
about it and when i got back in that
room closer to shaking if i'm sat down
thinking half of me was thinking yeah
yeah halfway
i'm just trying to focus on tv i didn't
know what we're watching
i just wanted to i was thinking just
just don't say anything fam and she'll
think you're up man
you're praying that there's not another
knock on the door you're praying all
night i was praying for that oh now i
was thinking please let them simmer down
because if they if they've been like
yeah yeah yeah say less and then they
come in again
i'm just gonna have to say babes let's
just
let's pack your bags let's get hotel
just come back to conferences
i can't face off with these yeah
so yeah luckily
five ten minutes later simmered down but
i came back in there sat on the on a
single bed i'm just pretty
i was thinking don't say anything
because my voice is going to be
trembling yeah yeah yeah it's going to
be higher
i'm proud of you yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
um you said you had a question no
yes so this is a specific would you
rather for you
so
would you rather
score a game seven buzzer beater and or
secure a winning knockout in the fifth
round of heavyweight championship boxing
match
that's actually a pretty good question
before you'd even said the second one i
was ready to be like
yeah buzzfeed will you talk about game
seven
um
fifth round
knockout
i'm just trying to think bro
or just
[Music]
probably buzzbeer why
because
um
i don't know bro there's just something
around i think it's the team camaraderie
because like if i if i get a knockout
like it's just me
like everyone could be gassed but at the
end of the day it's just me here when
you get that buzzer game seven you just
want everyone rings and pee
now they're grabbing you fam bro you're
getting carried out of there yeah
your team let's say you're uh lakers and
i'm [ __ ] uh pulling for example
you've got 98 points we've got 99 and
you just
fam about step back
cash as well bang everyone's going crazy
there's nothing like that i don't care
what anyone said
there could be nothing that can beat
that
you'll have that till you die
yeah rather than i just gave someone a
[ __ ] concussion
true i guess someone a concussion and
then a ref went yay
and then my coach was like gang sick we
go again in six months yeah exactly we
go again um but that buzzer beat will
live in you forever bro
oh i would rather have that cool i would
rather have that cool yeah it sounds as
soon as i said it and as soon as you
started to break it down something yeah
the buzzer beater sounds
sounds gravy oh your team are great
seeing you after that yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah oh that would be a most
amazing feeling bro i'm jealous that
i'll never have that
i'm jealous that i'll never have that i
know that's that must be such an amazing
feeling it reminded me of i saw a clip i
can't remember who they played um
what's the team called um where's death
play for again
golden state golden state i can't
remember who they played but i saw the
clip either yesterday or today on the
train i can't remember what it was um so
it must have been a recent game but it
was only in the third quarter so it
wasn't a buzzer beater but it was a
buzzer beater for the third quarter
i think they were down
i think they were down i think 98 99
something like it was something similar
to that and the opposition had just
scored at like 2.3 seconds left and
you're thinking yeah they're going out
within the quarter
steph halfway like
fakes the guy
and he just
and he as soon as he saw it he knew it
was going in as well cash
and you know he's how he celebrates like
that oh i was like
he's had too many of them you're the man
he doesn't get excited anymore it's just
normal he just takes his gum shield to
the side of his mouth and
i just does like a
yeah yeah if i'm he's he's getting it he
has to get mvp this year he's crazy he's
on stuff at the minute i'm pretty sure
the other week he got
a 50 bomb and then a 40 bomb the very
next game oh wow he's on smoke i'm
annoyed because i've not watched a lot
of basketball i haven't watched this um
this season
purely because the way my shift patterns
are patterning out
it's just not working for me i've not
seen i think i've seen
one game and i've never seen any live
game yet obviously because that dick at
the club yeah of course the time i come
back from work it's around that time
that they're usually on and most times
i've got the day off the next day
there's no game so it's like the i never
catch them i just never catch them so
i'm annoyed but yeah i need to catch up
mom fair play yeah man um i haven't i
will know you'll never catch me watching
live games i know you won't you'll never
catch me launch a live game um i don't
even watch like fights
like big boy fights like us i you see
the other week
oh that was a good ufc the other
someone's talking about the comments
okay yeah bro there was a good ufc the
other week it was um
right so the card overall was just on
smoke bro it was
um
now i can't even remember who [ __ ]
fought
it was
oh man right i'm gonna have to i hate
doing this but i'm gonna have to i'm
gonna have to check it was rose number
eunice was on there versus um
zhang wei lee
and that
was ufc 268 right cool
cool
so ufc 268 who did we have on the card
it was swingers throughout the whole
thing bro
swingers throughout the whole
justin gateshead bro
justine gaichy versus flipping um chana
michael chana okay
i know none of these guys right cool so
let me just put it into perspective
both um
so justin gaichy is a former champion um
he's in like conor mcgregor's weight
class okay so he's lost to
um
what's wrong with my name khabib
he's lost the khabib i don't think he's
ever thought conor he might have but i
don't think he has he's lost to khabib
um but before that he
sparked
uh ferguson ferguson's a beast sparked
ferguson um
so basically justin gaichi is like a
he's a decent boxer he's a very good
wrestler okay so he's and he's a he
don't care about his life bro okay so
he's got this weird technique where he
will just like he gives you the
impression that he's getting smashed up
so you he'll be you'll be boxing and
boxing him and he'll do this really
weird technique where he kind of like
cowers in to you so he ducks down and it
looks like he's just like getting shut
on so he'll take a couple
like kind of tuck into you power into
you for you to go in there ready for
uppercuts and as he's here fam he throws
one right over the top
and it
bangs people bro really
it
bangs people foohat
so he thought this guy called michael
china michael china is like five he's
small but he's like five six
jacked
shredded bro and he
his face took such an annihilation
it was ridiculous it was ridiculous bro
but like it was a war these men went to
war it was like these men were like
i just can't explain it it's just two
men that just were not willing to give
an inch and then every time you thought
something was happening like
would have that um michael chandler's
going off and you think oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
justin gates is here here here does his
overhand right bang and you can
literally hear the lever connect to his
face and
that's all you hear is smack
and then there's a microchip has to step
back yeah yeah and then just engage he's
on him family yeah and then it's
literally bang bang bang bang bang and
then out of nowhere michael china's
falling back uppercut smack and then
just in case he takes two sets no way
from them will go in toe to toe toed to
every single time you thought someone
was
doing something yeah yeah yeah bro
someone's clapping him the thing is
they're both really good wrestlers but
so they love standing up and fighting
that's what you love about the ufc is
like when you see people who spend all
their time on their feet
you you get the impression they can't do
anything on the ground
but the best ones are the people who are
born bred wrestlers so justin gaity was
like an all-american wrestler in like
college angle type in bro he's a
wrestler he's a wrestler he grew up as a
wrestler yeah that's what he does big
man so
you can it gets to a point where you're
just like cool like this guy's boxing
the [ __ ] out of me i'm gonna take him
i'm gonna take him down and we're gonna
work from the floor and you take him
down you're going to be sorry he's a
wrestler
he's going to grips you up so there's a
couple times where um there was one
where michael went for like a double leg
pick get you up like ready to [ __ ]
like almost like suplex him like ready
to do something to him picked him up
get itchy lent forward so say say i've
got your legs here so we're facing each
other here i've got your legs i've
picked you up here so your head's all
the way up here and i'm ready to slam
you down as i'm ready to slam you down
you've leaned all the way forward grab
the back of my legs
so then when i lean back to slam you
you've rolly polly and now you're on my
back wow
he did it like that wow
the tables turned through here
the back of his legs rolled him over and
he's on his back joking in fact i was
screaming
i was screaming bro
so there was that fight so who else was
on there
you said you don't watch these live you
watch highlights i watch i try and watch
i try and get the full fight if i can
um
oh don't tell me oh that was oozman
versus covington too as well oh my days
bro so yeah the the geichi fight wasn't
even the main card
yeah i saw the um oozman and whoever the
guy said i saw that there i saw there
what's the word i'm looking for they're
like they're way impressive oh right
yeah yeah yeah yeah right so um we had
the versus china then we had rose number
eunice versus zhang wei lee okay
scrappers
scrappers
um it's it's just it was too good to to
it was just you that fight you just have
to watch it there's there was no like
real moments yeah why you're like nah
nah
fam that you just have to watch it it
was a war and then um kamara usman
versus colby covington that's their
second fight um
their last fight they've got like a lot
of animosity between each other kobe
covington has this like really weird
like
almost like conor mcgregorish but just
like it's more transparent he tries to
over-the-top be a [ __ ]
but you can kind of tell he's really a
nice guy but he's just doing it for the
fight but even though he's just doing it
for the fight you're like you have to
bite really he just chucks it anyway
usually knocked him out in their last
fight so this is their rematch and it
was a lot closer usual won by decision i
can't remember if it was unanimous or
split it might have been split but um it
was a good fight so the whole card
was it for the belt for the yes so
usually the champion so this was colby
trying to get the belt off him again um
so they probably won't fight again now
like covers he's he's lost twice in a
row but um bro the whole card like
because when it's like they're not the
main event and you're watching the
undercard and you're watching geichi
versus china and it's a [ __ ]
scrappers both of them gate has been the
champion before
china might have been the champion
before but if not he's always been upper
right he's had fights against um like
conor mcgregor he said fights obviously
now against justin gage he fights
against the big boys so china's always
up there just to get a former champion
and they're not even the they're not
even the main event fan
the whole card was a hype the whole card
was a hype and then this weekend just
called me a max holloway versus um
who did i say it was yaya rodriguez yo
rodriguez has had a couple years off so
uh max holloway is like max holloway is
renowned as being like the best boxer in
the ufc okay he's got hands
fam
and yaya's had two years off
so
i think um max hollow was like the
favorite and he's maxwell was the former
champion as well okay max holloway was
the favorite coming in fam max holloway
came in confident little kaka kaka
he got kicked in his [ __ ] head like
10 seconds in
a solid whip
a solid whip to his temple 10 seconds in
and yeah i stood there like
literally what is it
no family took a kick to the leg you
heard it smack and it was like oh
and max said yeah yeah came in a little
bang in his head max
max's chin doesn't make sense bro he
took blows in that fight blows in that
fight he won
but that was another war jesus that was
another war this weekend just on last
weekend whatever um so yeah man the
violin was doing decent at the minute i
might need to jump on fam
you might you might need to jump i would
suggest it i would suggest it because
the ufc world is is nasty
um
but yeah man anyway i'm here for that
let's do um some red flags
oh
part two i forgot about that
before we do red flags have you did you
see or hear about
this liverpool vomiting
today i have like i haven't looked
anything into it whatsoever what is it i
saw it yesterday and i read a bit more
about it today
so
um taxi driver locked the suicide bomber
in the car before the liverpool
explosion
david perry's car was completely
destroyed in a fireball outside
liverpool women's hospital yesterday
morning killing the passenger in the
back who had who had asked to be taken
to the service of the remembrance at
liverpool's
um cathedral just miles away because it
was the remembrance weekend just gone
of course
um so perry suffered just two minor
injuries including a cut bruises and
damages to the eardrum
he has already been discharged according
to his friends yada yada so
sources sources have said that the man
in the cab asked perry to pull over
outside of the hospital when they
discovered that
they couldn't get to remembrance day
event because the streets were blocked
off
david noticed that david noticed the man
had some kind of light attached to his
clothing and was messing around with it
and he said he just didn't look right
and he said i don't know how he's done
it but within a split second with a
split second thought he jumped out of
his own car locked the guy in the car
and as soon as he locked the car it went
off
literally as soon as he would lock the
car
boom it went off
nah can you imagine bro
because as a as a taxi driver obviously
looking in in the rear view
if you sometimes you mind your business
sometimes you pre-order doing it well i
don't know i don't drive attacks yet
yeah of course but i'm assuming you pre
what they do once in a while you know
so if i'm seeing a little some like a
device or some lights
i'm not necessarily going to think it's
any form of bomber anything anything
like that last thing that's the last
thing i'm just going to think it's got
sighting on i don't know what it is it's
just something especially to ask to go
to remembrance or like a hospital you're
not really putting those kind of things
together
but for him to think this could be a
bomb imagine it wasn't
fam i'm actually dipped up the car and
locked him locked it he said pull over
just here i'll get out outside the
hospital and i was like yeah cool cool
dipped out the car
and then sprinted off i'm spread it off
and man's like
i'll be looking at the window like
what's going on what's going on
what's going on but luckily he did the
right thing at the right time boy
yeah but as soon as he locked the car
door bang bang let me show you the no
fam
no bro you went bang bro
[ __ ] me
to be fair there's a lot
it's one of them ones where they say if
he'd got out and blown up the hospital
which i'm assuming that was his that was
his intention yeah i'm assuming anyway
if a guy gets in your car acting shady
this is and then you imagine yourself in
the like police interrogation and
they're like so tell me what happened
okay cool so a guy gets in the car he's
a bit he's sweating he's a bit shaky i
looked at his chest he's got some
flashing ting going for his t-shirt he
keeps fiddling with it he asked me to
take him to the remembrance day event we
couldn't get there so we said oh you
know what just pull me up by the
hospital i'll get out of the hospital
um
and to be fair i just let him go
they'll be like what
he wanted to go to a remembrance day
event with a flashing light on his chest
and when he couldn't get there his next
best guess was a hospital
and you didn't think anything of it i'd
be like to be fair when you say it
outside out loud like that
i look like a suspect
it looks shady i promise you i just
don't care
man to man officer i just don't care he
collared the uber i pulled up fam i'm
just trying to do that job i'm kipp
doing my job it's hard
it's hard out here
that's all i'll be i've been doing
doubles for two weeks big man i ain't
got time to be thinking about lights on
chests
if he wants to get out of the hospital
and get out i just want to get paid bro
i'm sorry please don't implicate me in
this bro sorry
i'll be surprised
yeah fam shake it in the interview room
that was 100 thank you right now oh
course they'll pin it on me
they'll pin the whole thing on you
explained all of that and just said you
just let him go
fab the whole thing's on you implication
i'm going down for sight yeah 100 i'll
be so angry and even if you didn't you
can't roam these streets you could like
any man
yeah you're a traitor
on remembrance sunday you're a traitor
ah
the world would know my name for the
wrong reasons i'll be livid
i would be livid but yeah let's go back
to
that's a big red flag right there he did
well
i'm telling you now i would have ignored
it i'm telling you now i would have
ignored if you had probably shouldn't
get this guy out of my car i would have
been uh i don't know man i don't know i
imagine before i start before i do red
flags imagine
you put up to the hospital now obviously
none of this happened so this is all
hypothetical um you put up to the
hospital as the taxi driver you let him
out for some reason
you just decide to wait a couple minutes
maybe you're waiting for
the next person to come to slide into
your into your into your car because
you've you've swiped right away you've
done the thing
so you're waiting for the next passenger
now
three
two minutes past because you're waiting
for the guy and all you see in here is
boom
what would you do bro
but you see you see him you see him
walking to the entrance and as soon as
he
automatically doors closed
boom oh no it's him
i would know it was him for this
flashing lighting
it makes sense
it wouldn't even i wouldn't even be like
oh i would have been like i knew the
whole time didn't i
i looked it you know when you look at
yourself in the mirror thing like you
knew the whole thing right justin
before you drive off your sweat and you
like
before you pick the new passenger up you
got a yeah if i'm you knew what it was
the whole time didn't you you knew what
it was [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] but luckily boy he's um he's a
quick thinker but anyway here let's go
into um
part two and then wrap this [ __ ] you
man right
when the throat game is atrocious that's
a surely justin this is a guy right
oh this is a mix bro oh yeah so this one
exists yeah
so when a guy said with the throat game
is atrocious it's a red flag that's icky
man that's just an egg bro
yeah yeah
this is actually
borderline red flag can give banter but
can't take it
oh that is a red flag i hate that that
is a red flag bro i hate that because
with me right
my source of banter or my type of banter
like i'm just here i will insult you oh
what a million percent i will do that
i'm just insulting you but it's banks
you know yeah 100
100
so it's one of them ones where if you if
you chat [ __ ] and i take it and i chat
to you and you can't take it and you go
it's just like ah yeah piss off
literally piss off it's just bands bro
anyway
uh a man who doesn't clean his car
[Laughter]
don't you dare look at me like that
don't you dare look at me like that i
was i don't i didn't break i didn't
blink i was wait and you were gonna look
at me bro i try my best i try my best
speaking of slightly slight distraction
i try my best bro
i really do
but fam
the other day i was trying to i
literally got my car cleaning the other
day
i was driving around like a mug looking
for for um
a jet washed thing okay
i never even managed to get it done
driving around i went to three different
petrol stations oh they're people busy
the only one that was free only takes
coins like you can't go inside and get a
code and you can't use your card i don't
take its coins i didn't have the coins
for it i drive around looking for an atm
to go back then i got stuck in a traffic
jam that's like where i'm going looking
for the atm i got stuck in traffic for
like 15 minutes to the point where i had
fun i literally turned around i turned
around held the l that's long that is
all long yeah but sometimes my car is
kind of dangerous
um kissing their pet on the lips
yuck
immediate red flag yuck
absolute yuck
when they're constantly on their phone
i guess debatable you know you said that
last time did i yeah definitely
[ __ ] that one
oh when they take a shower in the
evening but don't take another shower in
the morning before they go to work
yeah wave it yay
you're not leaving it you're not leaving
this yard without getting in that shower
i'll tell you that
yeah [ __ ] flat yeah yeah yeah
some of what this is more of an egg
waste jokes
chips and mash in the same nando's meal
are you an animal
that's an egg that's hilarious
you can't do double potatoes
you can't run double potatoes you can't
you're not my misses bro you're not my
misses if you're running starch and
starch
starch
she's like you can't double starch fat
i'll get three wings oh do you want
sides um one or two i'll get to
what size you want chips and masks hairy
chips and creamy mash
i'd look at her and look at the [ __ ]
counter
dog
you [ __ ] dog
what are you doing
no garlic bread
nothing no minted peas chips and mush
nah you're an actual animal you're an
actual animal you are i'm sorry you are
yeah 100
when she spuds you like your bread drink
that's a bit ready that is a bit it's a
bit red i don't mind it because it's
quite rare i might the thing is i don't
mind it because i do it to a lot of
women oh yeah because i work well i spot
everyone yeah
um quick tangent or quick side
um about the spuds
i was at work the other day i was
speaking to
like two guests at one of the tables i
think i was pouring the water outside
and i was asking all the days blah blah
blah and then one of them looked up and
he was like
i know you from somewhere so here we go
i was like what do you mean you know
you're from somewhere she's like oh do
you do shits and gigs i was like yeah a
gang gang gang and she was like oh
that's the only podcast i watch and i
was like hold the spud you know so in
context you know i spud women like
fair play um he's like oh red flag or
when he goes to the studio
okay hmm yeah you've been hurt
she'd been listening too much ah yes
i'm in the studio man
i'm gonna call you back i know you hate
me yeah i know i hurt you but there's
more [ __ ] it now listen
uh when he said he was going to go pro
but he got injured
that's a typical bar yeah fam a typical
bar had trials anywhere you had trials
get out my face bro we can't be boys
when i have to ask if i can go on my
xbox or go out
you're in bondage brother
but i have to ask to go on my xbox or go
like yours or go out that's the thing is
that xbox one i can actually understand
some people might not get why i would
understand why but
sometimes like
us mandem can game fam
for hours i might not be contactable we
might be in the same yard and you can't
talk to me for the next six hours
sometimes it's appropriate to ask
permission like do you mind if i go on
the xbox tonight because you won't see
me i'm going to be honest i'm going to
be in here fam i'm going to be in the
living room but don't talk to me don't
touch me you won't see me bro and i'll
check in on you in a couple hours yeah i
would demand
you're a slave
you're a safe that's not a red flag
because you're in it
always on the phone when we're not
always on the phone when we're together
but too busy to reply when we're not
i like that one yeah yeah
asking to borrow money after meeting
once
that reminded me
a huge red flag that reminded me i don't
know if i've ever told you but i think i
have do you remember
uh not in them yeah
we've had this discussion on this bible
before yeah we have bro
when she told me the story about her
brand no i think it was a grand or four
four for some reason i thought it was
four but i knew it was in the four
figures
she lent donny she was seen for maybe
two weeks speaking to you for two weeks
maybe a month
lent him grands he ran off of course he
did he ran off of course he did he's
like what were you thinking woman that's
desperate she's naive vam shot i i've
got no sympathy for people like oh i
couldn't believe it when she told me it
was like oh right babes
bet no wonder you don't want to [ __ ] me
yeah
you've got trust issues now
trust this year's dead that man oh
[ __ ] hell man but yeah that's all the
red flags that's all the good things
anyway we'll get him with that all right
bless so guys
guys did the guys do i'm trying to think
did the guys do a little bit better that
time um i can't even remember probably
not because i kind of remember what
[ __ ] guy once did i think the the
nando's one could have been neutral
um
but yeah anyway guys
happy monday
scooting over to patreon yeah man get in
there in time for thursday and we'll see
you there level of love
[Music]